when was the last time they even
contacted us a decade ago they won't
defend us we need to do it ourselves
easy
violence is the last refugee i'm the
incompetent i know there's no man's
doctrine it's an observation i made when
i was younger than you would harry's
plan of assumed we'd wait for help or
hey guys pete here today i have a book
to show changes video for episodes three
and four of foundation i put this off
last week because i thought there might
be some movement on the vault and that
didn't happen but things are pretty set
up on terminus now so i think it's the
right time to talk about some of the big
changes there as far as spoilers i'm
going to be talking about the books but
i'm going to be talking about the stuff
that's happened up into this point in
the story i won't be giving away any
major plot points that might ruin the
series for you although this week i'm
going to talk about a little bit of what
i think they're doing and that's going
to pull some stuff that hasn't been
revealed in the show from the prequels
so if you haven't read those you might
not want to watch the end of the video
and i'll give you a second spoiler
warning so you can bail out there and
with all that out of the way let's get
into it
in my last video i talked about the
whole genetic dynasty the idea of clone
emperors is all made up for the show so
everything on that side of the story is
a change the one aspect of that that's
pulled from the books is ado demersel
who's in the story earlier and not in
this period of time that we're watching
i already went over that in the last
video so i won't do it again but i just
wanted to say that everything that goes
along with this new cli on the 14th the
one that's played as a teenager that's
all a mystery to people who read the
books as well one thing that's
interesting about that that i didn't
even see myself someone pointed this out
in one of the comments this new
character shadowmaster obrecht who the
young kleon interacts with about azura
he was in the first episode we saw
brother day order him to execute that
guy that was working on the painting and
if you look at him there 35 years ago
and then again in episode 4 he doesn't
look like he aged a day so there may be
something going on with him there and
that might tie into some of the ideas
for the bigger story that haven't been
revealed yet at the beginning of the
story the encyclopedist which is
basically what we're seeing on terminus
in the show there are two important
things happening anacrion's leader has
declared themselves a king and the 50th
anniversary of arriving on terminus is
coming up which means the vault will
open the people there don't know what
that means exactly but there's what's
called a radium clock counting down and
they know when to watch for it to happen
so this is something that they're
anticipating the starbridge attack and
cleon's decision to bombard an acrion
was invented for the show in the books
they're all right and they're starting
to act independently from the empire
they come determine as diplomatically
but they kind of do the whole nice
planet you got here sure would be a
shame if something happened to it saying
when they get there the encyclopedists
only care about working on the
encyclopedia so that leaves the first
mayor salvor hardin to figure out how to
deal with them while they're talking he
realizes that they don't have atomic
power anymore so he works that terminus
still does as a subtle threat into the
conversation to buy them more time so as
you can see all of that is turned around
in the show with enacrion being
desperate on a dying planet and we have
no idea how that's going to play out so
we'll come back to that in a future
video i mentioned the vault and this is
one of the major changes when isaac
asimov went back to write the prequel
books he mentioned in the epilogue of
the last one that harry selden sent gail
dornick to terminus to set up the vault
after they were already there the big
change on the show is that the vault is
on the planet when they arrive making it
mysterious and it hovers above the
surface emitting a null field that keeps
everyone but salvor from approaching it
in the books it's just basically a
chamber everyone knows that gail dornick
came there and installed it and that
something's going to happen on the 50th
anniversary the show moved things up a
bit to 35 years after they got there but
you have to guess that it was still
placed there by harry somehow and the
opening is still part of where the
show's heading
salvor is the warden instead of the
mayor and the whole idea of her
connection with it and being special
seems like they're blending a couple of
characters together that's what i'll
talk about at the end in the spoilers
section but here i'll just say that the
idea of some people being different or
special in foundation isn't as
antithetical as some people seem to
think that doesn't mean it's not jarring
to see salvor portrayed as more of a
warrior though i mentioned in my last
recap that it was a wtf moment when she
discredited the saying that violence is
the last refuge of the incompetent
that's the phrase the character is known
for and they relied more on their wit
than anything else it's still a bit too
early to tell if they're just setting up
a twist or if it's about the other part
of the character they've added to their
version of salvor though for that we'll
just have to wait and see
i also mentioned that i wish that they
would have developed the encyclopedias a
bit more mostly because there is a nice
tension with the way that they think and
what they're trying to do and what
salvor needs to figure out in order to
get through the crisis in the show they
changed things quite a bit by the
encyclopedist knowing what harry was
predicting in the books they knew he set
up the foundation that they were there
to collect this knowledge but not really
about how the empire was falling and how
they were going to be the ones who were
going to bring it back after the fall
that's only revealed to them over time
but when i thought about this some more
i guess the encyclopedists and what they
do reflects the bigger picture of why
the empire is failing and in the show
they just decided to show us the fall
through the genetic dynasty it's a
different way to get there but they
could still arrive in the same place so
those are the big things terminus is
more isolated it's a little earlier in
their development and acrion's coming
there with different motivations which
haven't been revealed yet the
encyclopedists are more of a mixed bag
they still rely on the idea of the
empire which is the same but they know
more about harry's predictions they
aren't waiting for the ball to open but
they are expecting that harry factored
in everything so there's no need to
worry they still have tension with
salvor but it's for different reasons i
don't care much about them removing the
idea of the decline of atomic power from
the periphery it wasn't the strongest
idea in the series but i do wonder how
things will change down the road as a
result so we'll see where it goes from
here now i'm going to talk about what i
think is going on with gail and salvore
and this is the part where i'm gonna
talk about book spoilers that might
spoil things for you if you haven't read
them all please like and subscribe on
your way out because this is your chance
to leave
by the end of the second episode it
seemed pretty clear that gail had
mentality powers at least the show's
version of what those will turn out to
be they made the character female put
her in a relationship with rach and that
produced a zygote that was put in
storage before she left in the escape
pod when you think of mentalix you think
of the second foundation which hasn't
been mentioned at all on the show yet
and when you think of rach's child you
think wanda selden the key mentality in
the second foundation's creation when
you combine that with salvor seeing
visions of rach coming from the vault it
seems pretty likely that she's their kid
and that her and gail are going to be
the genesis of the second foundation
there's plenty that isn't clear about
what harry knew or how he was involved
and that's why it's kind of frustrating
that they dropped that part of the story
for two episodes there's a lot of
questions after that in how things will
play out it doesn't really work if
salvor stays on terminus and who
actually knows which time period gayle
will wake up in there's also the outside
possibility that harry wasn't involved
at all in the show gail did say the math
was incomplete so maybe they're setting
it up that she wakes up and realizes
what's missing is the second foundation
it could go in a lot of different ways
but at least in broad strokes that seems
to be the direction they're headed with
them being special i'm curious to see
how that turns out and i think that's a
good place to leave things let me know
in the comments what you think just if
you're going to be talking about book
spoilers make sure you mark them please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon